mobilisés pour interpeller le
gouvernement des élus des communes de
saint quentin en yvelines du département
de la région députés et sénateurs se
sont réunis à guyancourt sur le site qui
pourrait devenir la gare de la ligne 18
sur l'agglomération tous présents pour
défendre la mise en oeuvre du projet
ferroviaire avant 2024
aujourd'hui les jeux olympiques c'est un
enjeu aussi fondamentale
on ne peut pas avoir deux discours dire
que nous allons recevoir les jeux
olympiques
appuyez s'appuyer là dessus au niveau du
cio à lima et ensuite derrière nous dire
que abane ont finalement n'aura pas
c'est impossible donc pour être rassurés
par le ministère il faut nous recevoir
rapidement et qu'on puisse avec des
entrepreneurs la population annoncer la
bonne nouvelle
cette bonne nouvelle c'est l'arrivée du
tracé de la ligne 18 dans les yvelines
avant les jeux olympiques avec une gare
située à guyancourt communes qui
accueillent 1200 entreprises et de
nombreux salariés au quotidien ça quand
on glisse et le deuxième pour l'économie
de l'île de france
on peut pas absolument pas du tout ne
pas avoir de transport structurants et
il faut qu'on se bouge nous
effectivement les élus les habitants les
entreprises et les étudiants pour faire
reconnaître que notre territoire est
incontournable un échelon proche des
politiques nationales certains élus
yvelinois ont des ressources importantes
pour peser sur la décision du calendrier
concernant la ligne 18
nous avons sollicité le préfet de région
pour lui demander là dessus des
clarifications pour lui demander une
étude de faisabilité sur le calendrier
qui pourrait demander à la société du
grand paris
nous avons un certain nombre d'éléments
naturels mans qui nous laisse penser que
boucler ce projet en 2024 jusqu'à
versailles
cette ligne 18 est tout à fait faisable
j'irai rappelé les engagements de l'état
au plus haut niveau et j'essaierai de
d'entrée
dans des bureaux qui aujourd'hui ne sont
pas encore ouverts je crois que les
ministères chargés de ce dossier sont au
travail qui vont remettre à un moment
donné leur copie au premier ministre et
et qu'à ce moment là une fois que les
hypothèses seront sur la table le
dialogue s'enclenchera avec les élus
locaux pour voir quelle est la solution
la plus efficace et la donne celle qui
sera de nature à répondre aux besoins en
marge de cette mobilisation des élus
écologistes de l'agglomération ont tenu
à exprimer leur opposition à ce projet